today new hope in the search for a
coronavirus vaccine drug giant pfizer
says it is in the final phase of
experimental vaccine trials
the company says early data shows its
product is 90
effective the fda's bar for
effectiveness is
50 and that means pfizer's shot
could get emergency use authorization
from the federal government in the next
several days
it's one of ten possible vaccines in
late-stage testing
this is an rna vaccine so these are the
instructions
for the spiked protein of cova 19 that
are ejected
in the arm and then the human body makes
the protein itself
and an immune response is made to it the
development comes as covet 19 cases
reach
new highs nationwide and there are
worries of an even larger spike very
soon
as you remember over the weekend tens of
thousands participated in mass
gatherings across the country
to celebrate and protest the
presidential election results
50 million doses of pfizer's vaccine
could be made available by the end of
the year